today is really about whether worldwide
web has come from it's hard to think of
any invention since possibly the
printing press that's actually had this
sort of level of impact and influence
but it didn't spring into being fully
formed it was really a very very simple
implementation of the vision that have
been around for decades so simple in
fact that when the the World Wide Web
first outing was a paper that was
written and sent to the ATM's annual
hypertext conference and it was rejected
on the grounds that something that
simple surely couldn't be considered to
be a hypertext it was just a set of
documents and pointers the roots of the
worldwide web really go back a very long
time and before modern digital computers
even back in the early part of 20th
century there was a scientist and
engineer called Vannevar Bush who was
American scientist he made his name
working on mechanical calculating
machines and he rose to be tremendously
eminent and during the Second World War
he became the director of the office of
scientific research and development it
was essentially the manager of all of
the American government research
projects that included the nuclear bomb
project and many many others
he was really the first scientist to get
to grips with a big modern bureaucracy
and it was what he found was vast
amounts of information flying around all
over the rest far more than any one
person can keep in their heads and he
looked upon that as a scientist as a
problem to be solved and in in 1945
in the last few months of the war he
wrote an extraordinary influential paper
that he called as we may think that was
published in the Atlantic Monthly in it
he addressed this issue of information
and knowledge that thinking could we use
machines to manage that and he
speculated about a possible machine that
he called the Memex a memory extender
which was basically an automated
microfilm reader and it was intended for
scientists Guzzi said in the paper there
may be one day every scientists could
have one of these machines on their desk
and it would contain all the scientific
literature published him and everything
and that's the idea of of this he then
started thinking about how you organize
all of the scientific literature ever
published and he started designing
systems of links and trails and guides
and such like and although the Memex was
never built I mean this was never
something that became real the thinking
behind it that machines could be used to
do this a fantastically influential some
decades later in the 1960s computers
started become mature enough to
potentially be able to do this sort of
thing and a number of really important
pioneers of computing started thinking
about this they were well aware of
Vannevar Bush's work there was somebody
called Douglas Engelbart Douglas
Engelbart lays a very great claim to
having invented our world he invented
the mouse window do user interfaces word
processing email he was recipient to the
very first email video conferencing the
list just goes on a lot but maybe that
could be another video but he was at
Stanford being funded by the government
but when they his funding came to an end
Xerox head
did a lot of his team and a lot of
Douglas Engelbart research team wound up
in Xerox PARC creating all the things
that they created there in any case
Douglas Engelbart was very much
influenced by Vannevar Bush and he
speculated that you could design
computer software that what he called
augmentation systems and an augmentation
system is something that augments human
intellect basically it makes people
smarter people it makes people better at
doing the things that that they do and
at the same sort of time from a very
different background there was somebody
called Ted Nelson
Ted Nelson was a writer really primarily
a writer he came out of the world of
movies his mother was an oscar-winning
actress his father was an award-winning
television director and Ted was looking
at this technology and Vannevar Bush's
thinking to see how this could be used
for literature and Villa teri purposes
and one of his really important books
city roads was in fact called literary
machines and Ted Nelson invented the
word hypertext and he designed back in
the 1960s systems that in many ways of
inspired modern hypertext systems and
the World Wide Web
his grand design but some natee called
project Xanadu which was a software
system that it was never really finished
in those days has been worked on since
and to some extent techno scene is still
working on it to this day the idea of
projects Anna do again as with Memex it
could store all of the world's writings
and literature and it would do that in
distributed service wouldn't it all in
one place but there would be servers
scattered all over the world that will
communicate over networks and all of the
material the content would be available
and people could create new material of
new content by quoting original sources
I'm taking the original material and
putting it into a new context but an
interesting part of this is Ted also
envisaged a micro charging system so
that the original content creators would
actually get revenue from their material
being quoted and put into new context
and there was also a layer of linking so
as well as the mechanisms of quotations
you can link from one thing something
else which is relevant than something
else
Xanadu was a fantastically complex and
visionary design and it influenced a
whole generation of computer scientists
who were thinking about these sorts of
things and then in the 1980s and up and
up through the early 1990s there were a
number of hypertext systems developed
mostly in universities as some became
commercial products there was a rather
wonderful system called gade gade was it
wasn't distributed it didn't communicate
on networks but you would create a
document a bit like an MS Office
document but it was a document designed
to be delivered on a computer full of
links and different ways of presenting
him information and guide was for what I
was developed in the University of Kent
but it for a while was a commercial
product and it was used for doing things
like developing online manuals and
training material and such like there
was another system called microcosm
which developed in the university of
southampton now this took the ideas of
Ted Nelson and Douglas Engelbart but it
embedded them rather than a piece of
software it embedded them in the
operating systems it your entire
operating system will become a hyper
media system and at the time that Mark
kruzan was around there were such thing
as Windows and you would install my
cousin on to your computer and it would
give Windows itself all of this
extra hypertext functionality of linking
and and various until things all of the
software on your computer would then
become a viewer into this microcosm
world again at this sort of time in the
early nineties the story which I'm sure
most people are aware of is Tim
berners-lee and also a colleague of his
Robert Collier working in CERN the
particle physics labs in Geneva and they
were interested in using this sort of
approach the whole ideas of hypertext to
help scientists share papers that they
were working on that was the original
intention of it and of course their
project was the World Wide Web and that
has changed the world spectacularly but
the really interesting thing is why
because the web wasn't the first
hypertext system is the dissenters we've
been around for many many years it
wasn't particularly innovative it wasn't
the best system in that it had less
functionality than many of these other
systems the stroke of genius and it's
the genius that really has changed the
world is nothing what's it walls but how
it was utilized because all of these
other systems were heavily protected
when there were research projects if you
wanted to use him he had to be research
collaborator and then sign
non-disclosure agreements and get
involved in the research if they were
commercial products they're often quite
expensive you need to pay a lot of money
to use these things whereas the attitude
of Tim berners-lee and what really
created the web far more than anything
technical was this is simple this is
free anybody can do anything they like
with it and very quickly people wrote
better web servers than the original web
servers and better web browsers in the
original web browsers and started adding
features to the very first incarnations
of the web a very simple by modern
standards they added graphics added all
sorts of other facilities and it was
that making it open to the world
throwing it's open to the world of geeks
that is what has changed the world more
than anything
technical it's very difficult for a
firewall of something to notice this
because these are valid HTTP requests
they're just super slow right and you
know maybe I've just got a really bad
internet connection
maybe yeah now this doesn't affect every
web server it mostly affects Apache